Ready Set Radio hot 97 five blazing
today's hottest music man bootleg kev
memphis bleek still in the building yeah
classic records but yeah you already
know so this what we gonna do man before
you leave ma'am I'm have you uh spit a
little some you cool with that I got
some I got some uh oh i know you're
feeling that that i'ma boss me write
that Meek Mill yeah yeah I got some I
think I put some down to that before I
wait to do that man once you drop that
finesse Memphis Bleek you already know
man hot 975 bootleg cabnet boo ask is
you already mine it's for my man fresh
see people say they want a rap back me I
got my top back posted in the bricks but
you better know that I'm strapped yeah
all by my lonesome but I'm out here
floating Christian bahama yoli designer
we smoke it yeah I mean that big will
throw me on that big will the most it
like a toy store mommy how our kids feel
now mo my grown a couple different home
ish yeah i watch home now I'm trying to
do my own you see me in the club popping
bottles of that goal and shooters in my
team come get hit with these explosives
people say hey looking for me see me
never shake do your homework on me that
you find out that we spray besides that
see them things I had out with me last
night hoping that Rosie I had them
higher than the gas price Jordy ass nice
and she got a face to match that come
around every corner so I call a ASCAP be
frank pass that piss me I like that see
you in the street that you be don't
wanna clap back on that bed stuy did i
do what God is trumping life after I'm
on that be ash [__] what's beef beef is
with my enemies road to Ed and I let the
King Rick in the middle of the street
you see the ghetto boys leave you boys
best retreat his wyndham shots blowing
leaving y'all six feet so don't never
confuse me with the stars don't we be in
them cars big guns be the cargo Marcia
lago Marcy go
Jones we're up to my Vegas squad yo yo
oh yeah I 975 bootleg cab Memphis Bleek